zuckerberg started facebook in a dorm
snowden exposed the NSA in a hotel I'm a
comedian who's been fired from many
social media jobs so what can I
accomplish if I'm locked in a room for
one week with just an internet
connection and a thousand dollars this
is control
[Applause]
so
the control room the challenge for this
episode is start an alternative medicine
company from inside this room now if you
guys don't know
alternative medicine companies there's a
ton of them but I'm gonna talk about two
goop and live water and I want to tell
you guys about these but I have to do it
in a special segment called my Viacom
approved opinions just a little bit of
background on this
Viacom the parent company of Comedy
Central hates this project they hate
everything about it just in prep for the
PowerPoint that I'm showing you now they
sent me two hundred and fifty seven
emails about things I am NOT allowed to
say one of the last ones was this that
just said it is our opinion that the
creative team should either change
course or stop development of this
project and most of the other emails
were about Gwyneth Paltrow or goop and
how I should not mention them under any
circumstance so in this segment I am
obligated to keep it positive so first I
want to talk to you guys about live
water if you don't know live water is
unfiltered unfiltered untreated
unsterilized spring water here's one of
their jugs from Instagram which I like I
think that that's good that's great
they sell a 2.5 gallon jug for $36.99
here's their real website people have
had a lot to say about this this guy
said without water treatment there's a
cute and then chronic risk stuff like
coli bacteria viruses parasites and we
don't have that because of our very
efficient water treatment process but
what does this guy know he's just the
director of the Healthy Living Program
at the Mayo Clinic so probably an idiot
i instead choose to believe again the
brilliant CEO of the company who says
tap water you're drinking toilet water
with birth control drugs in
they're putting in fluoride it's a mind
control drug that has no benefit to our
dental health and who would be more in
touch with nature and the human body
than this man who even in this press
photo is staring directly into the Sun
and so now I want to talk about goop and
I got to be careful but I'm just gonna
point a couple things out keep it real
straight forward this is goop's very
slick very cool logo that's important to
remember for later when I'm building my
company and then I want to talk to you
about some of their these are real
products that are for sale on the GUP
website this is their aromatic stress
treatment you can pick this up for 80
bucks and you get point one six ounces
this is their psychic vampire repellent
I thought it was weird that they
included instructions on how to use this
as if it's not obvious that this is a
product which you spray around the aura
to protect from psychic attack that's
clearly what it's for they have chilled
kid calming mists
that's 27 bucks and under almost all of
the products on the website not all but
almost all there's this cool disclaimer
that says these statements have not been
evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration this is not intended to
diagnose treat cure or prevent any
disease and I don't think that there's
anything wrong with me putting these
images next to each other I don't think
there's anything wrong with me saying
that's a great deal I don't think
there's anything wrong with me pointing
you know to these two images and
mentioning that goop is worth 250
million dollars I don't think is
anything wrong with me showing Gwyneth
Paltrow's beautiful 10 million dollar
home or putting this on top of it or
putting that on top of it and that's
fine and those are my Viacom approved
opinions so again back to the task here
my task was to start an alternative
medicine company and what that means is
that I want to start and operate an
actual company that has slick branding
that seems sophisticated which really
means European and and in order to prove
how effective those marketing tactics
are I need to make sure that the product
itself has to be a gross and dangerous
piece of nonsense so my idea for this
was a used tissue that works like a
vaccine in that someone sneezes on it
and then you have the tissue someone
else breathes that tissue in so that
they get sick now and don't get sick
later and the tissue itself costs $80
so the metrics I'm going to use to
determine whether this experiment is a
success is do people believe it will
people use it and do people like it so
the first thing I needed was a brand and
I used the haagen-dazs method how can I
miss it if you don't know is where you
take a product that's not Danish at all
but you give it a Danish name so it
seems fuller
so I went on Google Translate I typed in
tissue and it came out fav and I was
like yeah obviously that's the name of
the company are you serious
that's perfect what then I hit up my
buddy who's a graphic designer and told
him about the whole thing told him I was
locked in a room and he sent over these
mock-ups I've picked this one and so
that's the logo for the company and I
wanted a a slick package and you guys
have seen those like knockoff like
iPhone boxes right like they look pretty
much like the real thing but they're
fake turns out you can get those on the
Internet custom-made for 50 cents apiece
so I did that and it looks good and then
I was in the room I ordered a bunch of
petri dishes off of Amazon some
Kleenexes that i just balled up never
sneezed on and i started putting these
things together with stickers and gold
tape that I got from a craft store all
delivered to the room so this is the
logo on the little unit thing on the
back you see the same warning from the
GU products on the side you can see into
it you see this quote quote use tissue
and some of our nice gold tape it also
has instructions in English and Danish
it comes with two these cool stickers
that say blessed you on them so a little
tagline
it's like Apple oh and it also has this
trashcan on the back I don't know what
that means or what it is but I feel like
it's on a lot of products so it makes it
look more legit so I put a bunch of
these together and when it was all said
and done and taken care of this product
cost me $2 to make so I'm selling them
for 80 is the idea but I needed
marketing materials any good company has
them so again I'm locked in the room so
I spent a little bit of time writing a
commercial and then I went online and
found out that I can get like a casting
room and you can get it for like $34 I
put out an ad on La casting for people
to audition for this people came in to
play these roles in the commercial I
wrote and then to save money
I pulled every favor I could and I sent
buddies of mine that make videos and
stuff like that to my buddies garage and
Silverlake and they set up a shitty like
studio thing in the garage where they
did everything they could shoot this
commercial and I directed the entire
thing on FaceTime in the road and this
is the commercial we made you tear your
muscles to become stronger
you learn to fall to become a dancer you
callus your fingers to become a musician
why is your immune system any different
introducing a tissue powered by the
human body for the human body this flu
season keep your immune system feeling
like your immune system so that's the
commercial
[Applause]
so once all that was put together I
distilled everything down to a
Squarespace website that took like 15
minutes to set up it costs 18 bucks
super cheap and I also mark the products
sold out on the store so that it would
seem like there was this incredible
demand for the thing that doesn't exist
then I created a Twitter account bought
some followers and I use that to
announce all day long that we just ran
out of stock we sold out again and also
to retweet any article that had
something to do with Sean Parker so that
people thought he had something to do
with this and he doesn't but that's kind
of cool you can just do that if you want
it's easy then I set up this Instagram
page that has one of these like splashy
grid fit I mean it's but it
looks cool I think spent like 50 bucks
buying some followers and included our
little other tagline at issue unlike any
you've hashtag used before so now I had
a website a Twitter account and an
Instagram so once it was all in place I
was like I need a focus group to tell me
if people like this right so I went on
Craigslist and I searched like hey I
made a post I was like is anybody want
to come by and do this focus group I
went online I found out that you can
rent like a legit looking focus group
center for like a hundred and fifty
bucks and then I sent a camera crew to
go behind the one-way glass film
everything I also hit up my friends he
and Tran who's an amazing comedian so
the first thing we did was a product
demo so I could make it clear exactly
how disgusting and ridiculous this
product and this idea is and here's what
they say now we're gonna do a quick
product demonstration we'll have some
folks come in and they'll show you
exactly I have a streamlined version of
what's happening in the Copenhagen lab
and it takes five deep breaths petition
hashtag pass has issue would that be a
campaign and I do yeah yeah
what are some other hash hashtag
campaign ideas I just try to pass it on
pass they pass through these past days
keep your stick days keep your sick days
Janna
[Applause]
let's look into the pronounce and I
would love to see or hear your immediate
reactions for those so if you were to
see something about they've like this
anything has to do with a nose like that
is just gross look at this expression is
totally positive on that side are you
doing something positive with the tissue
so you're not thinking like the other
was negative this guy's doing these
Happy's doing something good for him
looks like I also like the red a lot
more than the blue and a gift that I
know there's a difference between red
and blue and one that's true that one
its power but I think the red is a lot
more of what I'm thinking this product
is about I think the red is a lot better
okay so to go to go back to the question
do people like it yes what so now that I
had a product that people seem to be
connecting with I wanted to find out if
I could hire somebody you know this
would be the ultimate test of like do
people believe it would somebody think
yeah I could work for a company like
that so I went back to Craigslist and I
made a post but I was looking for
something really specific keep in mind
this company has no real product no plan
and is possibly committing a crime so
there's only one type that's perfect for
this situation and that is a bro you
need
[Laughter]
you need a bro for this and I feel like
I found a perfect bro this guy I'm
talking about scotty babbitt AKA
blizzard as soon as i got the e-mail at
his resume i knew he was our guy because
he was in not one but two fraternities
in college and also under every photo
somebody had commented the word scoot
even when he showed up his buttons on
his shirt were buttoned incorrectly so
this was the guy this was our guy now I
don't have an office space for this so I
hit up my buddy and asked if I could use
his brother's office and if you have a
chain of white guys hooking you up with
stuff can you do anything you want yes
is that problematic yes so I have time
to get to it no let's move on the head
of customer service is the job that he
was interviewing for so I brought him in
for this interview and my friend Kyle
who's a comedian was the one
interviewing him and we set up a web cam
directly in front of his face but just
said that it was for a higher-up of the
company to review the interview later so
for this interview he's under the
impression that he's taking real calls
from real angry customers but what he
doesn't know is that those real angry
customers are me in the room and the
only instruction that he's been given is
to deny everything and no one can sue us
and so we were like let's see if he does
it so the first thing I did was called
and said that my son is sick and here is
what Scott had to say to this customer
son and he's very sick he's missed
several days of school and I'm already
falling behind in his curriculum how
long has this been for know should I
take him to the hospital
can you give me some background about
his son like what he does and stuff
every day he goes from 4 to 5 p.m. and
he comes home sometime around 7:00
nobody doesn't that money he takes the
Ola lesson what he talked to you about
like usually have anything I'm just
asking questions sir is he a
recreational marijuana user
these are teen years until 7 so what
he's doing for those 2 hours of 5 to 7
we should probably focusing on the
dynamic between you your son versus what
what that happens so fast he denied
everything and then unprompted he
started to deny things that we again
never told him to deny here's what
happened a second later in that
interview play basketball my wife
doesn't want him to what saviola you're
asking me what if the Ola is what are
you talking about you don't understand
my son I've just never heard of the
other of a viola sir you've heard of
violin and you've never heard of a viola
cello is yes it's right in between those
two instruments a real instrument you
just asked me what he does and I'm
telling you he plays viola he's very
talented so that is definitely made up
because if you lose
sermon you can google it so Scott's
hired he's got to be given upper sky
what
so again back to do people believe it
yes what people believe it so kind of
the last thing for me to do is find out
what happens when I take this product
into the world what happens if we've got
vaids
out there with people right will people
use it and most of the time when
companies have new products they have a
promo team go out and hand up four units
and the truth is I can't afford like a
promo unit like this but what I can't
afford is my girlfriend and her two
friends who conveniently did used to
work for redbull so this really only
cost me this 60 bucks to get these
matching polos made unfortunately the
one real edge that a company like that
has is these cool cars and obviously
this is crazy expensive and I'm Hawking
used tissues here I mean what was I
gonna do go on Amazon I get a bunch of
shipping boxes and then spray paint them
black and begged my friend if I can
borrow his girlfriend's Mini Cooper I
mean yes of course that's what I'm gonna
do yes and that cost about 80 bucks in
total and then the most expensive thing
on the entire project is this photo
booth that we rented but we told people
if you come in here and get a cool diff
for your Instagram you got to use one of
our youths issues but even with all that
it felt like there was still no way
people will use this on the street right
[Music]
it's free there's nothing weird about
this tissue but it's it's like that I
know it's like I knew immunity thing
even though yes someone did use it it's
like it's sterile sure if you want to it
is crazy
naturally Miami I you like we this is
like completely holistic
[Music]
so again will people use it yes yes they
will use it do people believe it yes do
people like it frankly too much really I
mean so the last thing I did this is my
last day in the room I was like can I
get some kind of press so I went online
I didn't have a lot of time at all and I
just googled like hey like is there you
know addresses of newspapers or whatever
that could send this to and then I put
together these envelopes of the babe in
them that cost me like 30 bucks for
postage it came with this little you
know postcard that says we're huge fans
of you and that there's a human sneeze
in here and it even outlined that this
is being sent by Oliver Oliver missin
the fictional Danish CEO of this company
that's not real unfortunately I didn't
have a lot of time in the room so I
didn't make him a face book I couldn't
make him like a LinkedIn or anything
there's no information about this guy
anywhere so I think that's maybe where I
kind of messed up on this part because
this company has no sales no CEO that's
you can find anywhere online it's not
incorporated anywhere it's not a real
company and a simple Google search will
reveal all that stuff so it would have
been nice to get like a little clipping
somewhere or whatever but that is
unfortunately the end because there's no
way anybody would write about this right
the world's boldest tissue company it's
called
babe tissue baby whoa baby wave tissue
baby
a pre infected used tissue for $30 a pop
and this one's apparently true is this
real like a nose in Time magazine boots
use tissues for $80 it's incredible Fox
News says the tissues have been sold out
for months now
tissues are in high demand tissues
company apparently has customers I want
to see those people over 200 different
types of rhinovirus are you better stuff
200 different types of tissues in your
nose expensive it's dangerous it's
disgusting and it won't work so
naturally it is sold out introducing
day.i you've contracted jugger times
this flu season keep your immune system
feeling like your immune system
[Applause]
but these tissues are so popular that
the company says that they have sold out
what do you guys think first of all so
the question is out of this app
[Music]
so to break it down what happened was I
put those in those envelopes and the
only people that got back to me I didn't
I don't know what was Time magazine and
we exchanged a couple of emails and then
after I left the room over a period of a
couple of months I did a bunch of phone
interviews as the fictional Danish CEO
Oliver listen and then time published a
seven page write-up about this company
that was packed with lies that this CEO
whatever guy said like a human sneeze is
safer than needles or pills I told them
that we have a stable of ten go to
sneezers and with and when they asked me
whether or not I paid the sneezers I
said I would rather not address my
relationship with those people
so the headline came out and it is it is
a little careful this is good journalism
on the part of Mandy Oakland ER at time
she included all this information about
like maybe it's real maybe it's not this
is a question is it real right but the
problem is other journalists at every
different publication who I did not
speak to didn't bother to read the 7
page time article and then started
running their own stories about it they
use words like virus infested and
disease in fact it's crazy
even the Time magazine hyperlink that
they posted is way scarier than the real
headline wave for the $80 use tissue
designed to make you sick that's
terrifying
and I didn't say anything to time that
was verifiable at all if any of these
other publications had looked into it or
read it they would have thought
something beyond you know we'll just run
this but they did anyway and the
question is kind of why and I think the
answer is it's exciting you know if you
if you're trying to sell ads and get
social engagement and run commercials
your story doesn't have to be true it
just has to be excited you know when Fox
News posts this their entire comment
section explodes like hundreds and then
thousands of comments about this that
say stuff like sounds like a liberal
idea and Obamacare would probably cover
it but it's not just people that hated
it every time another one of these
articles came out the product itself
that has no evidence of existing
anywhere online became more real every
time something came out I would get a
ton of emails asking when we were gonna
restock or if I had a baby strength
version that you could give to your
toddler but I think that's kind of the
crazy thing it's like you can manipulate
the international media if you have like
nine hundred bucks and take one
Photoshop class that's really you can do
this but also please don't do this
don't lie to people it's bad that's the
one thing I learned of this entire
process is that I suck for doing this
you know even the used tissue idea
itself was divisive people didn't know
if they they hated it and wanted to
leave me in comments or if they loved it
and wanted to restock but the one thing
that was perfectly clear that everyone
unanimously agreed on is that I am
extremely unlikable this is a potential
spokesperson this is someone that we've
tested in previous groups and it didn't
he did not test well what doesn't what
what is it about fitness glasses a nerdy
look the fact that he's white I don't
really believe he eats that much fruit I
don't believe people eat this much fruit
I sitting like what is it about you that
that makes you believe that he doesn't
eat that it's not so much that he's
skinny but it's his face this is not a
believable face to me I don't want to
buy from that guy okay Leanna is it
possible for them to consider using like
animation and said you know animation
yes okay are there any pros any positive
the fruit thank you so much
[Applause]
you